what we're doing is we're just sort of
rolling out some muscles so yeah get
involved in that do some basic shapes
snakes and what nuts halt train and
Jason Brom now go to work putting flesh
on the bones of their young t-rex should
probably go with the Pelican in this
order okay though I'll attach a working
initially in clay they'll lay out all
the muscles shapes and positions it's
not clear whether it loops around here
or whether I can just come over there oh
look they begin with the legs thighs and
tail speed sculpting it's all right here
so it turns in there like a little
string but yeah how thick would these
muscles be in a real tear a change how
would they connect with the other thing
I've come round in cross-section as it
goes over yeah so it would fill up here
so it wraps around like that yeah when
we study muscular reconstructions on
dinosaurs where a lot of times looking
at two-dimensional drawings but none of
which give us a 3-dimensional view of
how those muscles work how they how they
weave in between each other and how the
masses fill out no one knows what a
fully loaded t-rex looked like under the
skin so the team decides to check its
work against its contemporary cousin
this emu came from a local farm it had
suffered a crippling leg injury and had
to be put down but it may be able to
provide the answers they need aided by
Anatomy expert Katherine Shawnee the
team zeroes in on its long and muscular
legs they begin to peel back the
individual muscles that's that that's
the way that this goes together and to
sever them from tendons that hold them
to the bones yeah you know a lot of the
action of the running is coming from the
knee quite a wedge of muscle it's almost
wider than it is long as opposed to have
t-rex which just sort of longer than it
is wide
that'd be the muscle that does the job
Hall was talking about there is one
unmistakable difference between this
bird and the baby t-rex first of all a
t-rex would have a very massive very
long tail and the musculature between
the leg and the tail would be much more
developed than it is here
a t-rex like its other distant relatives
from the crocodile family controlled its
massive tail with huge muscles that
extended out from its legs while a croc
uses its tail to propel itself through
the water a t-rex probably used it for
balance
you